oh I do not appreciate this
Oh No well this is convenient hello
who's playing that piano no one is
playing no one is playing nobody's
playing but I knew it I know it
God is that you oh hell yeah my dipping
oh oh it's a it's a giant and theater
yes I can move grizzly
I wish grisly was a friend of mine I
think we could have been friends you and
me
god dammit crystal you are a genius
high-five hey hey grizzly I'm really
sorry you can't come with me
it's a scratches ah
Chrissy that was horrible hold me
grizzly I hear voices life stadium for
lease Delia for Oh chorus for acara
come here into Chinese speak Swedish
tequila [ __ ] you laughing I'm shut up on
a ai' you do with our Swedish that's
[ __ ] hot damn
where are we what am i doing my life I'm
sorry I'm sorry loudly
alright bro unfortunately that's all I
can show you until the game is coming
out in a couple of days maybe like if
you enjoyed watching and if you're
looking forward for em Nisha that
machine for pigs hit subscribe to come
over today and I'll see you in the next
one lay out the rest of you you are
going to them